nous vous avions promis la semaine
dernière une suite au micro trottoir de
gérard pas bio sur les illustres
inconnus alors et bien la voici comment
se fait-il que vous ne connaissiez pas
les essais de montaigne et parce que je
ne les connais pas j'ai eu le temps des
scènes nationales tout je connais arrive
je connais ce thème est ce que ça peut
être les essais de montagne votre avis
ça peut être un très bon joueur un
joueur de rugby
vous n'aviez pas entendu parler des eaux
des eaux mêlées de roger ikor non
alors qu'est ce que ça serait d'après
vous les hommes et les deux roger ikor
c'est un mélange d'eau chaude et d'eau
froide dans quel but
pour pratiquer pour la cuisine pour le
nettoyage pour tous ont le désert des
tartares vous connaissez le désert des
tartares teaser oui et tartas et le
dessert oui ça y est idiote
comment le dessert si on fait parler
comme ça et quand je vous dis la mort
est mon métier j'ai vu la très
sympathique et c'est sabatier bouger
sabbatique à trouver le précieux et 12
la mort est mon métier non ce n'est pas
notre métier c'est la vie entre les élus
les humains avec benoît a conduit à
gagarine
mais si je vous dis mon métier elle à
l'écran comme à la ville et qu'on
commençait de monde en otage
si je vous dis la femme de 30 ans de
balzac qu'est ce que vous en pensez
la femme de 31 ans de balzac ça fait un
peu jeune pour balzac vu qu à mon avis
ça doit être une question d'argent
je connais beaucoup de
deux femmes 30 ans qui vont avec des
personnes de 55 à 56 entre 55 et 65 ans
juste pour une question d'argent mais
pourquoi vous me dites chapeau votre
balle jaune parce que balzac déjà est
une personnalité personnes déjà riche
d'avoir un buggy
alors donc la femme de 30 ans c'est
juste les hauts de hurlevent ça vous dit
quelque chose
non non pas tellement donc est ce que
vous connaissez
léo ferré j'ai entendu par liszt
compositeur
si je vous dis agatha christie a fait
dix petits [ __ ]
pourquoi c'est bien possible que va se
disent à la fois qu descoings mais elle
a fait dix petits [ __ ] les a reprises
entre dans sa vie c'est la fête des
mères dans sa vie qu'elle en plus de 10
vous avez entendu parler le 25ème heure
de conte centre virgile géorgie n'ont
pas vraiment non et qu'est ce que vous
en pensez mais wentzinger je sais pas
saisir facilement réalisable mais
réalisable descendre les lotos de
travail 25 heures en 39 35
certains par semaine avez vous entendu
parler de la trilogie de marcel pagnol
je connais très peu mais enfin c est
malheureux qu'il ait eu cette maladie
qui dont marcel pagnol qui lui quelle
maladie en trilogie
qu'est ce que c'est la trilogie mais
voilà je sais pas c'est ça votre avis
c'est une maladie stérile eu
certainement enfin le rouge et le noir
ça vous dit quelque chose
oui monsieur ça me dit quelque chose
pourquoi je fais deux tapisseries du
canevas et je l'emporterai souvent au
nom non rouge et le noir
le petit prince de saint-exupéry ça vous
dit quelque chose oui bien sûr mais chez
pac c'est lui qui l'a chanté
comment est ce là lundi matin l'empereur
sa femme et le petit 13 cents venus chez
moi pour me serrer la pince mais comme
j'étais parti le petit prince à vie
puisque c'est ainsi nous reviendrons
mars
c'est ce lundi que je perds une
apparemment oui dit madame si je vous
dis qui josé mais est bien aimé moi